THE VOTE 145-61.
SEAN?
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, CHAD,
THANK YOU AS ALWAYS.
JOINING US THAT WITH MORE,
FREEDOM CAUCUS CHAIRMAN
ANDY BIGGS, SUPPORTING AN
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR FROM HER
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS.
ALSO JOINING US, THE AUTHOR OF
THE NEW BOOK FROM "THEY NEVER
LET A CRISIS GO TO WASTE,"
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JASON CHAFFETZ.
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLER
"FIREBRAND," FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
MATT GAETZ, WHO TODAY, EARLIER
TODAY, AUTHORED TO RESIGN HIS
PLACE IN CONGRESS TO HELP THE
PRESIDENT FIGHT IMPEACHMENT IF,
INDEED, NEEDED.
THE PEOPLE OF PENSACOLA IN THE
PANHANDLE NEED MATT GAETZ.
I’M NOT LOVING THIS.
PRESIDENT HAS GOOD LAWYERS IN
DAVID SCHON.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME FIRST GO --
THIS COMMENT TO ME, ANDY BIGGS,
IS SIMPLE.
IT’S UP TO THE VOTERS IN OMAR’S
DISTRICT AND OCASIO-CORTEZ’S
DISTRICT AND GREENE’S DISTRICT,
THEY SHOULD DECIDE THESE THINGS.
APPARENTLY, THEY KNEW A LOT
ABOUT ALL OF THESE CANDIDATES
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION.
WHY ISN’T THE SAME TREATMENT --
WHY DOES THAT GO TO THE
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NOT THE VIEWS ON
THE LEFT?
>> WELL, YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT,
SEAN.
ALL OF THIS WHILE SHE WAS BAKED
IN THE VOTE.
SO IF YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE OFF HER
COMMITTEE, THEN YOU NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THE CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, ALL OF THE HARD LEFT
RHETORIC THAT HAS COME OUT, ALL
OF THE VIOLENT RHETORIC THAT HAS
COME OUT.
HOW ABOUT SLEEPING WITH THE
ENEMY, BEING ON INTEL?
HOW ABOUT SPREADING FALSE HOAXES
AND RUMORS?
ALL OF THAT SHOULD BASICALLY
FORECLOSE THOSE PEOPLE, IF THAT
IS THE STANDARD, BUT THIS IS A
HISTORIC THING, BECAUSE THEY
WANT -- THE WHOLE BODY TO COME
IN.
WELL, THEY KNOW THEY CAN CONTROL
IT.
TO START REMOVING REPUBLICANS.
I TELL YOU, MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, IF THIS HAPPENS, WE’LL
JUST BE THE START.
THEY WILL GO AFTER A COUPLE
OTHER PEOPLE, THEN IT WILL BE
SOMEBODY ELSE, AND IT WILL
ALWAYS MOVE THE GOALPOST BECAUSE
THEY DON’T WANT A POSITION
ALLOWED.
AND DON’T FORGET, MARJORIE
TAYLOR’S A STRONG CONSERVATIVE
VOICE FOR WOMEN, AND THEY
DON’T WANT THAT, EITHER.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT,
MATT GAETZ, LET’S GET YOUR TAKE
ON ALL OF THIS.
I TRUST THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
THEY WANT TO ELECT YOU, THEY
KNOW THEY’RE GETTING A
FIREBRAND.
THEY GET TO DECIDE.
PEOPLE GET TO DECIDE ON
MAXINE WATERS AND NANCY PELOSI
AND OCASIO-CORTEZ.
YOU KNOW, HOW IS THIS DOUBLE
STANDARD -- THE WHOLE
IMPEACHMENT, LINE, CONSPIRACY,
ADAM SCHIFF’S -- HIS
CONSTITUENTS GET TO VOTE FOR
THAT PATHOLOGICAL LIAR.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
MARJORIE GREENE SAID SOME CRAZY
CONSPIRACY THINGS BEFORE SHE WAS
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
ADAM SCHIFF, ERIC SWALWELL,
JERRY NADLER, AND MOST OF THE
DEMOCRATS SAID CRAZY CONSPIRACY
THEORY THINGS WHEN THEY WERE IN
CONGRESS, IMPEACHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ATTEMPTING
TO DELEGITIMIZE HIS TIME IN
OFFICE AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THE
RUSSIA HOAX.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE GOT 75%
OF THE VOTE.
THAT’S MORE THAN --
>> Sean: THAT’S MORE THAN YOU!
>> THAT’S MORE THAN ALMOST EVERY
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
IT IS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT WHEN
WE DISRESPECT THE VOTERS, AND
THAT IS REALLY WHAT THE LEFT IS
TRYING TO DO.
THEY ARE SAYING THE PEOPLE OF
AMERICA DON’T MATTER.
IT’S THE DECISION-MAKING PROCESS
INSIDE THE BELTWAY.
SO TONIGHT, THE REPUBLICANS
DECIDED TO KEEP LIZ CHENEY.
TOMORROW, THE DEMOCRATS WILL
BOOT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE FROM
HER COMMITTEE’S.
I THINK BOTH DECISIONS REINFORCE
THE POWER OF WASHINGTON, AND IT
ONLY ENCOURAGES ME TO TRY AND GO
OUT IN AMERICA AND GET PEOPLE
FOCUSED ON THE CHANGES WE NEED
TO MAKE IN BOTH PARTIES SO THAT
THE VOTERS ARE RESPECTED.
>> Sean: I LEANED OUT THE
"HANNITY" CONSERVATIVE AGENDA,
THAT IS WHAT I FOCUS ON,
LIMITED GOVERNMENT, MORE
FREEDOM, LOW TAXES, LESS
BUREAUCRACY, CONTROL BORDERS --
I WENT THROUGH THE WHOLE THING.
CONGRESSMAN CHASE IT’S, LET’S
BRING YOU IN ON ALL OF THIS.
IT IS THE SAME DOUBLE STANDARD,
HOW WE DEFINE INSURRECTION
LANGUAGE, WRITE?
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP SAID MANY
OF YOU WILL PEACEFULLY,
PATRIOTICALLY ARCHED OF THE
CAPITAL SO YOUR VOICES WILL BE
HEARD.
WELL, CHUCK SCHUMER WAS
THREATENING TWO SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
JOE BIDEN THREATENS THE
PRESIDENT.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS BAILING OUT
RIOTERS AND SAYING THEY
SHOULDN’T STOP DOING WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
AND MAXINE WATERS SAID SHE WANTS
TO TAKE THE PRESIDENT OUT AND
KILL HIM TONIGHT.
ON GOING TO TAKE HIM OUT
TONIGHT.
ISN’T THAT A DIRECT THREAT?
SOUNDS LIKE IT TO ME.
>> YEAH, IT WAS A DIRECT THREAT,
AND THE DEMOCRATS CONVENIENTLY
FORGET ABOUT ALCEE HASTINGS.
ELSIE HASTINGS WAS PUTTING FIVE
PRESIDENT CARTER TO BE A FEDERAL
JUDGE.
HE WAS BROUGHT BEFORE THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES, IMPEACHED,
AND CONVICTED IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THE PEOPLE IN FLORIDA DECIDED TO
SEND IT BACK TO CONGRESS.
THAT GUY WAS CONVICTED OF
BRIBERY IN THE DEMOCRATS PUT HIM
ON THE RULES COMMITTEE, OF ALL
THINGS, AND YET YOU’VE GOT
SOMEBODY WHO SAID SOMETHING THAT
I TOTALLY DISAGREE WITH, BEFORE
AN ELECTION, BUT YOU KNOW WHO
GETS TO MAKE THAT DECISION?
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF GEORGIA.
NOT THE OPPOSING PARTY.
NOT THE DEMOCRATS.
AND NOT SOMEBODY FROM UTAH OR
ARIZONA OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA.
THAT IS WHERE THE RESPECT NEEDS
TO LAY.
>> Sean: I THINK THAT’S TRUE.
ALL RIGHT, ANDY BIGGS, WHERE
DOES THIS GO IN TOMORROW?
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, YOU KNOW,
AT WHAT POINT DO WE START
APPLYING THE SAME STANDARD?
ALL I AM ASKING FOR IS EQUAL
APPLICATION OF THE STANDARDS.
EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAWS.
YOU KNOW, DUE PROCESS UNDER THE
LAW.
WE DON’T SEEM TO HAVE ANY OF
THAT IN THIS COUNTRY TODAY.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
TOMORROW, IF IT GOES LIKE I
THINK IT’S GOING TO GO, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE VOTES.
THEY WILL PROBABLY REMOVE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
THAT IS WHY I COSPONSORED THAT
AMENDMENT, WHERE WE SUBSTITUTE
ILHAN OMAR FOR MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO
GET 1 FOR 1.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO TAKE OUT ONE
OF OURS, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
OUT ONE OF YOURS.
BUT WE ARE STILL IN THE
MINORITY.
BUT WE’VE GOT TO GET THE
MAJORITY BACK IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY THIS.
BUT I TELL YOU WHAT, WE’VE GOT
TO -- WE HAVE TO KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THIS, BECAUSE IT IS SO
DISPARATE, THIS TREATMENT HERE,
AND WHAT NANCY PELOSI HAS DONE
TO TRY TO IRRIGATE POWER TO THE
CENTER.
THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
WHEN THIS IS JUST ONE MORE STEP
IN THAT.
>> Sean: MAP?
WHAT’S MEANT TO HAPPEN TOMORROW?
>> TOMORROW, THEY ARE GOING TO
TAKE THE UNPRECEDENTED ACTION OF
SUBSTITUTING THE WILL OF
WASHINGTON FOR THE WILL OF
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND WHEN WE GET THE MAJORITY
BACK, WE BETTER APPLY THE SAME
STANDARD.
SO OFTEN, I SEE THE DEMOCRATS
ACTUALLY FIGHT TO WIN, AND
REPUBLICANS ARE PLAYING SOME
PATTY CAKE GAME.
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT IS NOT THE
CASE, THAT WE POINT OUT THE
HYPOCRISY ON THE DOUBLE
STANDARD, BECAUSE IT IS EATING
AWAY AT OUR VOTERS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: AND JASON, YOU HAVE
SAID IT PUBLICLY, TOLD ME
PRIVATELY, IT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS YOU GOT FED UP WITH
CONGRESS.
>> I DID.
YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS, WHEN THEY
GET INTO POWER, THEY TRY TO BE
DEMOCRATIC MIGHT, THEY GO EASY,
THEY DON’T PLAY OFFICE.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING IS
BEYOND OFFENSE.
IT IS A DANGEROUS, DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
BUT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
REMEMBER, WHEN THEY HAVE THE
POWER, AND THEY HAVE THE VOTES,
THAT’S WHEN THEY HAVE TO MAKE
THEIR MOVE AND STOP BEING
DEMOCRATIC LIGHT FOR GOODNESS
SAKE.
MAKE THE CASE, WOULD WRECK THE
ARGUMENT ON THE FLOOR.
THAT IS WHY MATT GAETZ AND BIGS
AND OTHERS, JIM JORDAN, ARE